oh god I feel nauseous I need some water  [Music]  stop it god damn  cut the crap guys I was waiting for your  line ask you well why did Billy cut to  me if you weren't done with your line  yet just cut the crap there what's the  problem what's the problem we came here  to have a nice time not watch a bunch of  disgusting creeps well I guess you have  a point yeah yeah I'm sorry sorry  apology not accepted you creeps ruined  our anniversary  let's go Darlene let ye among you  without sin cast the first stone is that  the point I guess and we're back up  there and I go don't apologize to me  apologize to my wife and we widen out to  see and you maybe hold her hand and  comfort her I'm so so be careful  Ronnie's leaving with her  Ronnie couldn't wait well I guess it's  cut time to get down time to guard  shelters they haven't spotted you yet at  Chow Christina  [Music]  you